Do you have any thoughts on red light therapy?
Does it compliment the right or not?
So, yeah, I think the red light and green and blue light therapy can be beneficial.
I think where red light therapy, so red light therapy is at a very specific frequency.
I can't remember what it is like 640 nanometers or something like that.
But I do not believe red light therapy has a great physiological benefit below a few millimeters of the skin.
I'm not saying that any effect on the germal of the skin doesn't affect the core.
There can be a reflex effect on the core.
But I think sometimes there's too much emphasis on red and green and blue light therapy.
But I think there can be benefit.
Does it compliment the right?
Yeah, it can compliment the right.
So, you can do them together.
You can do them at the same time.
You can do it different times.
There's no harm in doing light therapy.
There's no harm in doing red light therapy.
So, absolutely, go for it.